[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue à toutes et à tous sur figaro
live on est en direct sur lefigaro.fr
sur youtube et sur twitch pour vivre
ensemble l'un de ces rassemblements
nationaux en hommage à samuel pâtit cet
enseignant de 47 ans assassinés de façon
barbare vendredi soir en région
parisienne rassemblement ce moment place
de la république à paris avec cette
place juste derrière nous avec sylvain
châtelain pour figaro live et vous
l'entendez peut-être on va vous fait
revivre ça cette clameur et ses
applaudissements
une nouvelle fois en nous
[Applaudissements]
peuvent rouvrir
voilà de nouveaux applaudissements en
hommage à samuel pâtit on vous a fait
vivre ça et c'était déjà la troisième
fois que la foule ici présentes à taper
dans ses mains en hommage à samuel bâti
47 ans beaucoup et bien de simples
citoyens qui sont venus avec une
particularité est liée à la crise
sanitaire des messages écrits sur les
masques chirurgicaux 1 vous savez ces
masques bleu ciel qu'on est très
nombreux à porter aujourd'hui je suis
prof je soutiens les preuves voilà ce
qu'on peut entendre alors que là le
public la foule applaudit la nouvelle en
ce moment
[Applaudissements]
voilà
vous le voyez en direct sur figaro l'ex
sur ces images de sylvain châteaulin la
foule qui continuent d'arriver qui
cherchent à s'introduire sur cette place
de la république qui est d'ores et déjà
bondée c'est assez impressionnant la
station de métro n'est pas fermée et
chaque rame de métro envoie sur la place
des centaines et des centaines de
nouveaux manifestants
ça arrive de toutes les artères autour
de la place toute cette france qui est
en colère et à la fois effrayée par ce
drame qui s'est donc déroulée vendredi
en région parisienne beaucoup de
messages je défends la liberté
d'expression freedom of speech
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir sur une
pancarte noires aux pieds de la statue
il ya quelques instants beaucoup de
soutien au monde enseignant je suis
enseignant je soutiens les profs on a
même avec sylvain chiasson quelques
profs en colère qui sont venus nous voir
en nous disant mais mais on se sent
oublié on ne parle pas assez nous de ce
qu'on vit il ya aussi beaucoup je vous
le disais un de messages de soutien sur
les masques chirurgicaux qu'on voit sur
les visages de nombreux participants
alors que nouvelle salve
d'applaudissements pour a vu en direct
retenti sur la place de la république et
même aux abords
[Applaudissements]
on peut vous interviendrez dans trente
secondes c'est quote ok merci en cause
d'une question simple vérité des faits
abonnez vous
voilà on est toujours sur figaro là ils
vont en direction figaro.fr sur youtube
sur twitch on va profiter et bas du
calme de ces deux petites minutes entre
deux salves d'applaudissements pour
interroger bien l'une des participantes
à cette mobilisation c'est clair bonjour
clair merci d'être avec nous alors vous
me disiez vous êtes étudiante cé sa
politique
alors comment est ce que vous avez
appris cette tragédie vendredi j'étais
en train de travailler j'ai reçu une
notification et hassan a un peu choqué
étant donné du contexte et surtout que
ça vienne sur un enseignant fins et ce
sont des personnes pour voir protéger
quand c'est une fonction sacrée un petit
peu de la république et je pense que là
ça atteint un seuil un petit peu limite
je voyais dans votre main on va montrer
ça sur les images devant la caméra de
sylvain châtelain vous êtes venu avec
une photocopie d'une d une de charlie
hebdo et c'est ce que je voulais vous
préciser tout à l'heure c'est beaucoup
de manifestantes et manifestants sont
venus munis de
une de charlie hebdo ou est-ce que vous
pouvez nous la livre du coup islam
religion de paix éternelle
je vous laisse j'ai envie de vous
demander pourquoi vous avez choisi celle
là en particulier du coup en fait on l'a
distribué dans les dans les rangs de la
manifestation mais je pense que c'est
important en deux défis défendre la
liberté d'expression et voilà que tout
le monde ne peut pas partager le même
avis assez clair mais tout le monde a le
droit de s'exprimer penser ce qu'il veut
tant que ça ne promet pas la violence et
anvers autres justement ce concept de
liberté d'expression il revient beaucoup
depuis ce tragique attentat
on va laisser passer trente secondes les
applaudissements et de vous poser la
question suivante clair
voilà nouvelle salve d'applaudissements
je vais vous poser comme question claire
on entend beaucoup parler de liberté
d'expression depuis 48 heures vous
justement qu'est ce que vous mettez
derrière ce concept qu'est ce que ça
évoque pour vous la liberté d'expression
pour moi c'est la liberté de dire ce
qu'on pense
voilà dans un cadre tant que ça ne
promeut pas la violence envers autrui
voilà chacun on est en république on a
la liberté de pensée la liberté d'agir
et c'est important qu'on me dise ce
qu'on pense pour faire évoluer les
choses et chacun a sa place ici en
france dans la république et la meinau
démocratique nous sommes chacun à sa
place et doit dire son avis est ce que
on assiste aussi à une dérive d'une
véritable déferlement de haine désormais
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
puisque ce drame par finalement dû d'une
page facebook oui mais les réseaux
sociaux tous leurs définitions
permettent de promouvoir la haine
malheureusement c'est une des dérives
mais je pense que voilà chacun en tant
qu'individu doit pas être capable de
faire la part des choses et de savoir ce
qui est bien ou mal j'ai envie de dire
mais ce qui ce qui tout ce qui est
violent et évidemment à bannir malgré le
contexte sanitaire c'est important pour
vous pour le devenir aujourd'hui oui
pour moi c'est important je pense que
voilà on a tous fait qu'une grande crise
on est en train de vie encore de vivre
une grande crise sanitaire qui est en
train de nous désunir j'ai envie de dire
que petit à petit et je pense que c'est
important d'avoir des moments de d'union
et de montrer qu'on est là malgré le
contexte est difficile et on en a encore
pour des mois mais voilà il faut montrer
qu'on n'est on est là et on est heureux
d'être ici
merci beaucoup que l'inde d'avoir dans
ce contexte un réagi en direct pour nous
jean paul ii est étudiante à à
paris-dauphine merci beaucoup voilà come
back l'air qui est étudiante nombreuses
autres étudiants sont venus puisque
cette mobilisation a lieu à l'appel de
syndicats
lycéens de syndicats étudiants
d'associations aussi comme sos racisme
et puis il ya également des leaders
politiques qui sont présents on parle de
jean luc mélenchon pour la france
insoumise julien bayou secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
olivier faur premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste ou encore stanislas guérini à
la tête de la république en marche
julien qu'une aile à la réalisation de
ce rêve que je salue à nouveau me
glisser dans l'oreillette que la mer
paris anne hidalgo ainsi que le premier
ministre jean castex sont en ce moment
sur la place de la république alors vous
avez sans doute remarqué
où vont se situer donc ça va être vous
pouvez le voir sur les images actuelles
nous on est un petit peu en périphérie
vraiment ils foulent extrêmement compact
on peut sans se mouiller et dire qu'il
ya d'ores et déjà plusieurs milliers de
personnes combien ça on le saura en fin
d'après-midi au mieux avec les chiffres
des autorités de la préfecture de police
de paris en tout cas mobilisation
intergénérationnel vous l'avez vu une
étudiante à l'instant des enfants aussi
un peu plus tôt qu'on a pu remarquer
observés dont on a pu remarquer la
présence dans la foule et je crois qu'il
ya une prise de parole en cours qu'on va
essayer de vous faire vivre
faisait bloc contre l'intégrisme en
compte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
d'autres associations ici présente le
bras aps la ldh et tous les autres qui
estime que la république est en danger
nous sommes en deuil aujourd'hui mais il
faut que tous ceux qui sont contre les
valeurs de cette république nous
chérissons qu'ils sachent qu'ils sachent
que nous ne combattrons jusqu'au bout
par notre humilité et par notre
attachement à ces valeurs liberté
égalité et fraternité
je veux appeler monsieur dominique sopo
président de sos racisme
bonjour bonjour à tous et merci d'être
aussi nombreux sur la place de la
république
vendredi il se trouve que j'étais
moi-même en cours puisque je suis aussi
enseignant aux mains nues
j'étais moi-même en cours de mc avec des
élèves dont nous parlions de démocratie
et dans le même temps ce que je ne
savais ça évidemment un de mes collègues
étaient assassinés dans les conditions
effroyables que tout le monde a pu
constater
dans ces circonstances dans ces
circonstances il était important de se
rassembler il était important de se
rassembler j'entends bien les gens qui
disent mais à quoi bon se rassembler je
pense que il faudra s'inquiéter le jour
où lorsqu'un homme aura été fait pour
avoir fait son métier
il n'y aura plus personne pour se
rassembler je constate que ce temps
n'est pas venu et j'espère tu ne viendra
jamais et s'il faut se rassembler c'est
pour rappeler quelques principes simples
d'abord que les hommes
de cet attentat motivé par minute est
logique que nous pensons aujourd'hui à
samuel passe-t-il
que nous pensons aux siens
ça va
ce
hélas
je
[Applaudissements]
parfait
non
toujours en direct un surfer bref pour
couvrir ce rassemblement de place de la
république à paris en hommage à samuel
paty et on est donc évidemment direct
sur youtube et tout on est avec
christophe qui est avec nous ou
pancartes qu'on a pu apercevoir avec
sylvain est écrit que je suis avec elle
pour la liberté et que je suis contre la
terreur terreur qui s'est abattue sur
sur ce collègue est ce que c'est
important pour vous de venir aujourd'hui
ah oui oui je crois que là c'est c'est
notre arme à nous d'être c'est une
démocratie donc c'est en france on est
une démocratie donc c'est le pouvoir du
peuple et donc c'est le peuple qui dit
qu' on est contre cette attitude là
d'actes isolés de personnes qui ceux qui
sont contre les idées qu'on défend et
contre notre les bases les fondamentaux
de notre république
une question a une expression qui
revient beaucoup évident que les 48
heures c'est défendre la liberté
d'expression alors ça ne figure pas sur
votre panneau mais qu'est ce que vous
mettez derrière ces mots là ça va
beaucoup plus loin pour moi parce que là
c'est la liberté de vivre et c'est de
cette personne qui a assassiné
cet enseignant elle a refusé la liberté
de vivre de cet enseignant parce que
parce qu'elle n'était pas d'accord avec
lui parce qu'il a publié des caricatures
qui l'estimaient offensante pour pour
pour la fois qu'il avait donc ça va bien
au delà de la liberté d'expression c'est
ce sont nos libertés ce sont nos valeurs
qu'il faut défendre ici et c'est en
train de gagner parce qu'on on est tous
là et c'est le fait qu'on soit tous
contre cette personne qui a isolé
puisqu'ils sont pas si nombreux que ce
qu'on croit ce sont des gens qui sont
finalement peu nombreux et on peut
gagner on va gagner si on est tous
rassemblés sur les mêmes valeurs et tous
les défendre comment vous avez appris
cette terrible nouvelle
vendredi à parler par les informations
l'information est effectivement c'est
extrêmement choquant d'apprendre ça j'ai
envie de dire le dernier jour de cours
alors que l'ensemble des enseignants à
partez en vacances et de voir que à
cause de ce qu'il enseignait et à cause
du fait qu'il enseigne en plus la
liberté d'expression qui est la base
fondamentale de la république c'est avec
ça qu'on avance c'est avec ça qu'on a
construit notre pays que ils sont
assassinés à cause de ce qu'il fait à
cause de son travail et a co saisi des
idées qu'ils défendent des idées de la
république va y a rien de pire je crois
que rien de pire c'est intéressant
justement de selon vous de réfléchir en
cours comme ça c'était un éduquer un
cours d'éducation morale et civique
c'est intéressant de partir de ces
caricatures justement pour réfléchir
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas je moi je
pense que effectivement ces cas là en
france on a le droit de l'as fait n'est
pas ce qu'on à la liberté d'expression
et donc ses caricatures elles doivent
pouvoir être re publiée comme l'a fait
charlie hebdo elle doit pouvoir être
utilisé pourquoi pas en classe
effectivement après je pense qu'il ya un
travail à faire effectivement parce que
c'est des choses délicates où
effectivement ça peut
blessés les enfants et parents d'élèves
de confession musulmane a effectivement
et donc il ya tout un travail à faire
mais en france c'est la liberté
d'expression donc effectivement c'est ça
a été publiée on a le droit de la
justice n'a pas dit que ça aux français
la religion donc on a le droit de les
utiliser mais je pense qu'il ya tout un
travail à faire collectif pour pas
laisser un enseignant essayé de
l'utiliser et peut-être employé des
termes ou des activités sur cette
surface que ces caricatures qui peuvent
prêter à confusion
donc c'est un travail collectif à faire
l'éducation nationale de sites et je
pense qu'il faudrait pour l'utilisent
tous pour les équipes estime à 1 des
mots qui revient une des expressions qui
bouche des études sur des élèves et
collégiens qu'avait samuel ou de ses
anciens collègues
c'est l'aimer faire débattre et
finalement débattre ce verbe le mot
débat est-ce que c'est plus un des plus
beaux moments finalement un démo qui
s'imposent de plus cette liberté
d'expression en france
oui exactement vous savez pouvoir
réfléchir dossier de pouvoir discuter
dessus et de pouvoir mettre des mots sur
tout ça puisque là c'est là finalement
c'est sinon c'est la peur qui va gagner
alors que c'est pas la peur de gagner ça
la démocratie c'est aux libertés de
gagner c'est à nos valeurs et là on
gagne je me suis sûr on gagner merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci christophe on
remet votre votre pancartes avant de
vous quitter merci beaucoup et bonne
mobilisation
voilà comme christophe et bien ils sont
des centaines à avoir bien
fait le déplacement avec des pancartes
avec des messages écrits de leurs mains
comme c'était le cas avec christophe ya
quelques instants ou alors avec des une
de charlie hebdo on voyait tout à
l'heure clair notre étudiante parisienne
qui avait une de ses mines de charlie
hebdo à la main d'autres bas ont collé
c'est une sur des pancartes
il ya également pas mal de représentants
du monde enseignant on voit des hashtag
je suis prof des hashtags je suis
enseignant je vais d'ailleurs aller
essayer d'interviewer l'un de ses
professeurs
on est
fut ce trail au figaro on est en direct
sur le site du figaro et sur notre
chaîne youtube
j'ai vu sur votre tête ce hashtag je
suis prof est ce qu'on peut vous poser
quelques questions ouais alors vous êtes
prof justement vous êtes vous enseignez
mon épouse et mes profs d'accord je suis
venu pour la soutenir ils sont tous là
voilà et pour vous mais du coup c'était
vous êtes venus en famille on est venu
ouais on couple ouais malgré le contexte
sanitaire c'était c'est trop important
c'est c'est ça suffit ça suffit
la liberté d'expression on a le droit
c'est justement
[Musique]
ja
voir
un contrat
à
[Musique]
voilà nouvelle salve d'applaudissements
ici aux abords de la place de la
république et sur la place de la
république évidemment souvent dont des
milliers de manifestants se trouve on
est toujours en direct sur lefigaro.fr
sur youtube sur twitch en direct avec
également sylvain et julien à la
réalisation d'un direct avec christelle
bonjour tristesse
merci de répondre à nos quelques
questions pour vous c'est évident de
venir aujourd'hui ici ouais c'était plus
qu évident c'était plus que huit ans
c'était un vrai appel autour de
effectivement là là
comment dirais-je l'amour de
l'enseignement la pédagogie et
et cette violence gratuite qui est
incompréhensible
comment vous avez appris cette terrible
nouvelle vendredi
c'est mon mari qui me l'a appris samedi
matin en fait les informations samedi
matin est le premier mot la première
réaction qui vous est venue cette était
quoi injustice violence liberté liberté
bafouée liberté d'expression bafouée
quand on s'en prend comme ça un
professeur un enseignant on touche à
quelque chose de fondamental dans la
république
on touche aux racines de la démocratie à
la capacité de s'exprimer à celle
d'éduquer à celle de pouvoir
effectivement échanger des idées
discutées
tout ce qui fait le sel et l'importance
de la démocratie
vous êtes vous-même parents d'élèves je
suis parents de trois enfants est ce qui
vous raconte justement ce qu'on leur
enseigne dans les cours d'éducation
morale et civique les eaux cm comme les
zones c comme on les appelle et et comme
ces cours finalement qui est du cas les
secours dans le but qu'elle est partie
bâti que cette affaire oui en fait ils
ont ils échangent régulièrement c'est
vrai que nous on avait plus charlier on
a vécu aussi tout ce qui se passait
autour des caricatures il on parle oui
et al ahly maison on en parle et c'est
des sujets très ouvert qui font comme je
le disais aussi la richesse des
discrètes de nos discussions et la
richesse de la france
alors ce qu'on demande à tous les
manifestants et manifestantes qu'ils
sont là
on en commet vous vous définissez la
liberté d'expression votre définition à
vous c'est quoi c'est de pouvoir
exprimer chacun des idées qu'on a au
fond de nous qui viennent de nos
cultures de nos différences
de ce qu'on a vécu est de pouvoir les
échanger avec dans le respect des autres
et avec les coudes pour pouvoir aussi se
forger des opinions et s'enrichir ce
soir un conseil de défense à 18 heures
autour d' emmanuel macron quelle doit
être la réponse de l'état selon vous
suite à ce terrible attentat
j'en ai aucune idée franchement
aujourd'hui j'avais pas comprendre si on
si on peut si on peut finalement se
passe passe je sais pas je ne sais pas
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir dire je pense que
c'est malheureusement c'est assez
imprévisible et ça va prendre du temps
pour pouvoir rassurer et assurer une
j'ai du mal à le dire mais une sécurité
pour les enseignants et pour nous tous
c'est une ax inexplicable vous avez dit
que tout à l'heure que vous êtes maman
de trois enfants est ce que justement
que vos enfants vous en avez parlé ce
week end
oui les enfants ont parlé ils sont
maintenant des pour certains des
adolescents et des adultes
oui il ya eu twitter dès le samedi matin
et les uns et les autres ont pu voir les
images
et c'était extrêmement chaud mais je
suis mon nom merci beaucoup en tout cas
christelle merci beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà toujours en direct sur figaro live
le figaro.fr tweet chez facebook vous
êtes nombreux et nombreuses à réagir
dans nos différents chat à nous faire
part de vos remarques sur et bien la
tenue de cette mobilisation eu égard au
contexte sanitaire et notamment aux
chiffres bas qu'ils ne sont pas bons du
tout en concédant qu vides à paris et
bien effectivement ça peut étonner
on le comprend mais on peut aussi tout à
fait comprendre l'urgence de se
mobiliser
après ce dramatique assassinat vendredi
en région parisienne toutefois la la
place semble-t-il commence à se vider un
petit peu on a vu aux alentours de 15h
10 15h15 déjà des personnes notamment
des personnes âgées et bien chanter la
marseillaise applaudir quelques dizaines
de secondes et s'en aller pour essayer
on imagine
pour essayer de conjuguer à la fois
mobilisation contre cet acte barbare et
protection face à la crise sanitaire et
là vous le voyez peut-être sur ces
images de sylvain châtelain des
mouvements de retour qui s'amplifie un
petit peu un contrairement aux
mobilisations des autres années
évidemment cette année la plupart des
gens vont rester très certainement moins
longtemps on a devant nous des enfants
je sais pas si vous les voyez avec une
pancarte touche pas à mon prof avec une
main verte
on a on aperçoit quelques dizaines de
mètres la france est devenue sa propre
caricature
un manifestant qui a voulu jouer sur
sur ce mot caricature
on l'évoqué ya quelques instants avec
les différents manifestants
différents français qu'on a rencontrés
il y à il ya quelques minutes
alors je ne sais pas si on est des
images en direct d'autres villes
j'interroge julien à la réalisation
on va vous montrer tient pour faire il
n'y a pas qu'à paris qu'on se mobilise
aujourd'hui on va vous montrer ce qui
est en train de se jouer du côté de
lille du côté de lille où là aussi on
conjugue mobilisation et protection face
au virus puisque lille fait partie des
huit métropoles françaises qui sont
concernés par le couvre-feu 1 depuis ce
week-end il ya des mobilisations
également à marseille à rennes à lyon
même dans des villes plus petites comme
rodez comme béziers comme saint lô en
normandie
toute la france se mobilise aujourd'hui
pour dire non pour rejeter cette cette
barbarie
onze personnes on peut faire un p'tit
pot ainsi sur sur l' enquête des
précisions ont été apportées on sait que
11 personnes désormais sont en garde à
vue vous avez pu suivre hier sur figaro
live la la conférence de presse du
procureur national anti terroriste jean
françois ricard qui on l'imaginé va
redonner des précisions dans les jours
qui viennent au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée de l'enquêté et des avancées
sur les éventuelles complicités
vous continuez de réagir dans le tchat
on va vous montrer dans quelques
instants aussi des images en direct de
toulouse et on va rebasculer à paris et
vous continuez de réagir et de poser vos
question également de témoigner votre
soutien aussi on relève au message de
soutien et de condoléances pour samuel
samuel pâtit cet enseignant
d'histoire-géographie de 47 ans qui
enseignait donc au collège du bois
d'aulne à conflans-sainte-honorine dans
les yvelines et qui a été sauvagement
assassiné vendredi en rentrant à son
domicile
[Musique]
le
non
bref
il
[Musique]
le talent
à l'école
quand
[Musique]
mais pas tous
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il
ce qui est impressionnant
voilà
[Musique]
vrai
avec ses désirs
m
non
avec
si le gia janvier
m
je
c
oui
voir
la réunion
[Musique]
toujours en direct de la place de la
république à paris et de ses abords sur
figaro live merci d'être avec nous sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitch sur youtube pour
bien suivre avec nous cette mobilisation
l'une de ces mobilisations ce dimanche
après midi en france en hommage à samuel
pâtit cet enseignant
d'histoire-géographie de 47 ans
sauvagement assassiné alors qu'il
rentrait du collège du bois d'aulne à
conflans sainte honorine vendredi soir
conflans sainte honorine dans les
yvelines la foule la foule commence à
quitter la place de la république
vous pouvez d'ailleurs le voir sur ces
images de sylvain châtelain plusieurs
milliers de personnes c'est une
certitude on attendra en fin d'après
midi les chiffres officiels les chiffres
des autorités
on a vu tout à l'heure sur un autre
point de cette manifestation
le départ des dirigeants de la france
insoumise il y avait jean luc mélenchon
il y avait à drillien cat-nat le député
du nord
la présence de la france insoumise
faisait polémique notamment
vis-à-vis de leur participation à une
marche contre l'islamophobie c'était il
ya quasiment un an le 10 novembre 2019
des figures proches des frères musulmans
étaient dans le cortège et
et la présence de la france un soumises
à cette manifestation avait alors
engendré une polémique non à la barbarie
islamiste et le charlie hebdo de
septembre tout ça pour ça le numéro qui
a été publié le numéro spécial au moment
du début du procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 et bien voilà une pancarte
et un journal que qu'arbore 2
deux dames qui viennent de quitter le le
cortège vous continuez un de réagir de
nous poster vos commentaires nous poser
des questions aussi si vous avez des
questions sur la mobilisation sur les
autres dirigeants politiques qui étaient
ou sont toujours présents on est à votre
disposition au relais sur lefigaro.fr
sur twitch sur youtube également
[Applaudissements]
pearson président de décider
séverine directrice de dessiner créer
liberté ça fait plaisir de voir du monde
comme ça il ya cinq ans au lendemain des
attentats de janvier 2015 avec charlie
hebdo les ostracismes nous avons créé
l'association dessinée créée liberté
l'association d'éducation médias au
désert presse à la caricature et à la
citoyenneté
nous avons créé cette association parce
que nous étions guidées par le même
sentiment que sa nouvelle bâtie par la
même existence et par les mêmes valeurs
nous voulions transmettre et d'éduquer
ouvert des portes aux jeunes en leur
donnant bouquet
parfois beaucoup
m
je pensais
jusque-là temps
ça n'est pas tout
ça
[Applaudissements]
ce
m
où
non
un peu plus de 16 heures ça fait donc
plus d'une heure que ce rassemblement a
débuté place de la république à paris
on va saluer évidemment notre communauté
sur lefigaro.fr bonjour françois bonjour
tristan bonjour strobl qui est également
là
un bonjour à mohamed également alors on
voit passer un commentaire qui nous dit
il est très difficile d'accéder à la
place de la république vous avez raison
et ça souligne l'ampleur de la
mobilisation cet après midi toutefois il
est un petit peu plus facile d'accéder à
la place depuis quelques minutes puisque
de nombreuses personnes sont en train
de partir pour conjuguer en l'imaginent
mobilisation et protection sanitaire
rappelons quand même que paris et
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
sont concernés par le couvre feu et où
les indicateurs épidémiques sont assez
alarmants continuer de nous poster vos
commentaires et 2
donnez vos réactions tout en respectant
la charte et là je m'adresse surtout à
notre communauté sur youtube vous êtes
signalé avec des commentaires très
intéressant dans nos derniers là il va
continuer comme ça et là
ne rajoutons surtout pas d'huile sur le
feu ou surtout pas voir dans les tchats
d'appel à la haine ou ce genre de choses
ce n'est absolument pas le but de ce
live
ni le contexte
en tout cas je vous le disais tout à
l'heure on a vu certains responsables
politiques sur cette place de la
république on a aperçu jean luc
mélenchon le leader de la france
insoumise
le député à l'efi adrien quatre mains
sont les a aperçus quitté la place tout
à l'heure on voit pas mal des chars
tricolore alors de figure qui nous sont
inconnus mais on imagine que ce sont des
maires de communes d'île de france
notamment des des adjoints à la mairie
de paris anne hidalgo anne hidalgo la
maire de la capitale était au coeur de
cette place de la république tout à
l'heure on a pu vous avez pu le voir
vous avez pu voir les images avec le
chef du gouvernement jean castex qui
était présent lui aussi
on attendait aussi du côté des ministres
je ne sais pas si on les a vus passer
sur les images mais on attendait jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
de la jeunesse et des sports ainsi que
marlène schiappa la ministre délégué en
charge de la citoyenneté agenda chargé
pour le gouvernement du moins pour une
partie du gouvernement puisqu'il y aura
un conseil de défense autour d' emmanuel
macron à 18 heures avec bien évidemment
le ministre de l'intérieur entre autres
gérald darmanin qui sera là et qui sera
ce soir l'invité de tf1 à 20 heures dans
le journal de 20h et
aussi bien le premier flic de france
fait de d'ores et déjà de nouvelles
annonces concernant
et bien la lutte contre la
radicalisation éducation éducation
éducation touche pas à mon prof c'est ce
sont certains messages qu'on peut lire
en ce moment sur les pancartes amené à
porter par toutes ces sommes toutes ces
femmes tous ses enfants aussi beaucoup
de jeunes présents ici on a vu un petit
garçon faire un dessin avec une colombe
tout à l'heure alors à même le sol je
sais pas si c'est très compatible avec
le contexte sanitaire en tout cas on l'a
vu terminer son dessin on a pu
interroger et bien des des époux des
épouses de professeurs des parents
d'élèves
au cours de ce live on va évidemment
essayez de vous montrer d'autres acteurs
présents à cette mobilisation on
attendra aussi les chiffres de la
participation qui devrait être connu en
fin d'après midi plusieurs milliers de
personnes ça c'est une certitude
désormais on va voir combien de millions
on va voir si on dépasse les 10 mille
personnes mobilisées ici place de la
république à paris je vous laisse vivre
ces images en immersion
toujours dans le cortège avec sylvain
chomet
non non non
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Musique]
ah bon
mais jamais
[Musique]
non mais
toujours sur la place de la république à
paris pour suivre cette mobilisation en
hommage à samuel paty et vous le voyez
sur ces images de sylvain châtelain les
kurdes eux aussi mobilisés on va vous
montrer ça d'un peu plus près les kurdes
solidaire avec les enseignants je vous
lis qu'on peut voir sur les pancartes
tous unis contre l'horreur jihadistes
nous avons vaincu le califat nous
vaincrons aussi sa mentalité
les kurdes qui ont été en première ligne
pour affronter évidemment le groupe etat
islamique en syrie notamment vous voyez
c'est l'être sur les drapeaux y pgp gay
je crois en lui
sans lui
nous sommes tous genres lee nous sommes
tous sans mots elle nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous sens noir
nous sans doute joly nous sommes tous
dans l'ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sont pas
[Musique]
à
ce que je sais
[Musique]
voir maintenant
le temple
est ce que tu vas faire une
en fait on n'a pas envie
je
bailly
[Musique]
d'autres
je poussais
[Musique]
[Rires]
son enseignement à tout le moins masqué
toxic qui nous protège de rien du tout
c'est comme ça qu'ils sont traités les
enseignants ou
on est le socle de marbre
c'est toutes ces valeurs là du tout
chaque citoyen de
et bien c'est aussi grâce à lincoln
m
détruit cet outil extraordinaire pour
former des citoyens ça
annick ont été des années des années et
des années quand vous dites me
moi j'ai enseigné pendant pendant dix
ans
on a un lycées sensibles et heureusement
ça extrêmement
courage qui recevait des menaces de loin
à longueur de temps
quand on exclut un élève quand on cumule
pourtant pu prendre des sanctions
aujourd'hui compromis
c'est vrai qu'entre basse à la limite on
va pouvoir finir au tribunal
mes parents d'élèves se mêlent depuis la
gauche notionnels de notre évaluation
et on a des prises sur à lyon que deux
monde
enlève même l'esprit critique dans notre
façon de jouer
on a des grilles d'évaluation du pitbull
les yeux que les endroits où on doit
compter les points sur des critères
totalement discutable pour nous empêcher
de vous fait chier si on est enseignant
n'a pas depuis cinq ou six ans moi j'ai
fait une prépa extrêmement difficile
or on arrive à un niveau les enseignants
en tout cas je prenais est titulaire
parce que
enseignement
de taka par des gens tirent pas parti
cet accroc à 12 djiboutienne
c'était un drame c'est un fan absolu
nouvelle carrière de l'entrisme de
passer
islamo fascistes au p 7
c'est à dire ce n'est pas si mal que ça
que n'ont pas la formation il faut que d
autres des pauvres a lancé et on est
souvent très peu de gens à longueur de
ses nous et 2 et de bfm tv
parce que parce que quand on est
effectivement quand on nous fait ses
comptes et crème on s'imagine que ces
corps
et on nous laisse de mer
un salaire de nous
ce qui est bien aussi la preuve de
l'absence de reconnaissance absolue
qu'on a aussi dangereux
et alors épouse est bon alors du coup je
comprends tout à fait conseil en colère
pour parler aujourd'hui
est-ce que je peux prendre votre contact
pour une autre fois ci on fait des
reportages
et
[Musique]
l'équipe d'avoir notre café salut elle
pâtit on méritait une femme tient on
énergie à la société et là je pense que
son travail nous aurions quelques
secondes
nous travaillons qui cherche à expliquer
à des adolescents ce qu'une caricature
cette minorité
c'est lumineux alors diffusé lé compte
l'esprit des lumières alors reprendre
qu'en france
[Musique]
le moment parmi les bandeaux singer se
faire 2006 numéro part du management
c'est la nuit des trophées remis aussi
ont saigné ont signé la liberté le
respect des autres formules minorité
[Applaudissements]
d'enfants très mal assassiné un
enseignant c'est assassiné l'école de la
république
ce qui caractérise l'acte d'enseigner
c'est le dos le don d'une connaissance
qui permet à l'autre
[Musique]
interview
nouvelle forme
labrecque
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on voulait faire monter
voilà on est désormais au coeur au coeur
de cette mobilisation est au coeur de
cette place de la république à paris
cette mobilisation en hommage à samuel
pâtit cet enseignant de 47 ans vous
voyez les différentes pancartes dans les
mains des manifestants ceci n'est pas un
sujet de débat c'est l'histoire
contemporaine de mon pays notre pays
peut-on lire sur ce morceau de carton
avec d une de charlie hebdo juste à côté
il ya cette pancarte dont je vous
parlais un petit peu plus tôt freedom of
speech liberté d'expression on peut voir
là c'est ce n'est pas une pancarte c'est
plus sain
une sorte de poster qu'on a dans les
mains d'un manifestant vêtu d'un chapeau
je suis musulman et je suis contre la
violence
peut-on lire sur le mène sur la fiche du
manifestant voisins je vais vous parler
de cette interview
alors cette interview dont on vous a
diffusé un extrait mais les personnes
interrogées ne souhaitait pas apparaître
en direct à la caméra il s'agissait de
laetitia et jean marie un couple
d'enseignants pour l au lycée
à ses proches ainsi qu'aux
à ces élèves et aussi à l'ensemble la
communauté qui a été visée dans cet acte
odieux
lepron qui m'a gêné dans son france leur
désarroi
nous sommes d'ici là répond c'est toi
c'est pour marquer d'entretien incorrect
droit la liberté d'expression et
d'opinion sans lequel il ne peut y avoir
de droit à une éducation pleine et
entière comme le rappelait hier
dunja mijatovic commissaire aux droits
de l'homme du conseil de l'europe dans
des mondes que nous faisons nôtre la
liberté d'expression est la pierre
angulaire de la démocratie est infime
partie des trois chantiers verts sort
des trois enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les droits de tous les citoyens de tous
les soirs chez la femme en sorte que des
compressions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
[Musique]
cette mesure
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
enfin la paix
là
petit
vous
il faut
[Musique]
les égouts
trois fois
[Musique]
vendredi dernier
ça
[Applaudissements]
prenant à se respecter les autres
il est piquant de devenir des adultes
responsables
pour cela il a une
[Musique]
cela
il a été
la république et de ses abords pour
cette mobilisation en hommage à samuel
bâti au coeur de paris alors la place de
la république qui commence à se vider à
se clairsemer mais il ya quand même
beaucoup de monde encore vous voyez le
voir les quelques instants sur nos
images on est un peu plus près est
vraiment compris nos excuses et quand il
ya des petites coupures
parce que effectivement encore la foule
est assez compact et quand il ya du
monde le réseau ne suffit pas toujours
et du coup il peut arriver que l'image
se fige
on essaie dans la mesure du possible de
basculer sur des images d'agencés de nos
confrères de l' agence france-presse
ou de zapper mais même de leur côté sont
pas toujours possible donc voilà désolé
pour ces petits moments de latence en
tout cas je voulais vous parler d'un
témoignage que j'ai pu recueillir il ya
quelques instants vous êtes peut-être pu
entendre le début mais on a été coupée
un témoignage d'un couple d'enseignants
assez fort alors malheureusement il ne
voulait pas passer en direct sur
figuerola ni sur aucun autre média
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils nous ont eus
m'ont dit on est trop énervé là on est
vraiment sous le coup de l'émotion et de
la colère après ce qu'il s'est passé
vendredi on est trop énervé on va pas
réussir à se contenir six ont 6 ans
témoin dans direct mais on a échangé
vraiment un échange très intéressant et
qui nous a permis d'aller au delà
de cet assassinat barbare de vendredi et
de creuser un peu sur ces mots au sein
de l'enseignement français en tout cas
du corps professoral
que ce soit pour les collèges les lycées
je sais pas
l'euro
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça
un vague
pour c
on préserve toute humilité
je vous
les menaces de mort des menaces de mort
et elle m'a dit et puis pour nos
professeurs les menaces et ces
permanences les permanences et une
mauvaise note
une autre en tout cas jugée trop basse
par certains parents et bas certains
parents viennent nous demander des
comptes et nous menace on exclut un
enfant pareil on doit se justifier on
est comment dire pointé du doigt ça peut
aller jusqu'aux menaces voire les
menaces de mort et ça on n'en peut plus
on n'en peut plus et on ne se sent
absolument pas soutenu par la direction
voilà pour le témoignage assez fort de
ce couple
enseignants qu'on a pu recueillir il ya
quelques instants qui était toujours
sous le choc et sous l'émotion
évidemment moins de 48 heures après cet
assassinat
la place de la république qui se vident
d'autres mobilisations avait lieu dans
de grandes villes françaises qui sont
pourtant elle aussi touchée par les
drastiques mesures sanitaires et le
couvre-feu toulouse lille notamment
on vous a montré des images tout à
l'heure grâce à julien à la réalisation
place de la république qui est en train
de se vider jean castex et partir ils
étaient présents le chef du gouvernement
à ce rassemblement place de la
république et quelques dizaines de
minutes
programme chargé pour une partie du
gouvernement puisqu'il y aura un conseil
de défense à 18 heures autour d'
emmanuel macron alors est-ce qu'il y
aura en deux heures à peine des mesures
de prise sous entendu est ce que gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur pourra
faire de premières annonces pour tenter
de rassurer notamment basse on le
découvrira au journal de 20 heures sur
tf1
en tout cas merci d'être avec nous sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitch et sur youtube
pour vivre cette fin de mobilisation
on va dire alors qu'on voit à l'image
sur ces images de sylvain chacun envoie
yannick jadot
yannick jadot qui a conduit évidemment
victorieusement la liste europe écologie
les verts aux européennes l'année
dernière
alors on voit donc julien je viens
pardon yannick jadot est justement
julien bayou étaient attendus dans ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui lui qui est le
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts la voyait toujours l'image
donc le député européen peu élevé
yannick jadot on a aperçu aussi un peu
plus tôt jean luc mélenchon les dents de
la france insoumise accompagnée de
plusieurs députés de son parti notamment
adrien cap 9 on les a aperçus quitté le
rassemblement c'était il ya eu une heure
environ
et jean castex qui lui aussi a
est parti on a pu voir également
l'association
sos racisme qui fait partie de ces
associations de ces entités qui ont
appelé au rassemblement aujourd'hui tout
comme
bien des syndicats lycéens étudiants
comme la fage la première association
étudiante de france journée journée de
rassemblement qui était soutenu bien sûr
par charlie hebdo et on a pu voir on
peut les voir encore dans le cortège
s'est c'est une de charlie hebdo c'est
une qui remonte à 2015 pour certaines
qui sont beaucoup plus récentes pour
d'autres notamment cette une du numéro
qui avait été publiée au moment de
l'ouverture du procès des attentats de
janvier 2015
en septembre vous avez pu voir notamment
l'une de ces une justement de de charlie
hebdo avec la première interlocutrice
tout à l'heure qu'on a interviewé une
étudiante claire étudiante dans une
université parisienne à la porte
dauphine et qui nous expliquait que
c'est une justement incarner incarnait
la liberté d'expression la liberté de
blasphémer libertés fondamentales en
france un discours qu'on a pu retrouver
dans la bouche des autres manifestants
qui sont venus ici vous avez pu
apercevoir aussi tout à l'heure les
kurdes des kurdes qui sont venus avec
leur drapeau et leur message nous sommes
charlie nous sommes samuel ont-ils dit
entre autres il y aura un hommage
national pour samuel pâtit ce sera
mercredi on vous le fera vivre
évidemment en direct sur sur figaro live
et vous pouvez continuer en tout en
respectant la charte a continué je vais
continuer de commenter de réagir et nous
poser vos questions sur le figaro.fr sur
twitch ainsi que sur notre chaîne
youtube
ce sont les islamistes interdits
il faut que nos libertés pour nous en
priver et nous sommes là ici et je
remercie d'être plus particulièrement
des 30 toujours au côté des voix
progressistes et l'ail dans la clarté la
ville contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme étant aussi importante
et fondamentale que la lutte contre
l'islam politique et cette idéologie qui
ce sont des intégristes de notre
religion
quand on dit ils ne parlent pas en notre
nom c'est vrai que je ne représente pas
la majorité mais pour les convaincre il
faut les reconnaître comme étant des
extrémistes de notre religion qu'on doit
convaincre y compris théologiquement et
ce sont les français
oui
révolution
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
résistance en colère parce que nous
avons réussi sa rentrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci votre présence merci aux
différents intervenants d'être venu
aujourd'hui on peut appeler des
principes le principe simple est
important je tiens à faire remarquer
pour quoi faire rassemblement encore un
rassemblement il faudrait qu'ils aillent
se rassembler c'est par m c'est un
peuple que nous sommes ensemble
c'est un acte que nous sommes fermes sur
les principes qui sont ceux de la
république sont ceux de la liberté de
conscience qu'ils sont seuls de la
laïcité est temps que se rassembler
c'est déjà le début de quelque chose
évidemment se rassembler ne va pas
changer une fois les journées
l'accueil est déposée et un acte d'une
telle gravité symbolique que ça aura des
conséquences dans la société des
conséquences profondes
n'oubliez pas que ceux qui commettent
ces actes ceux qui les guident sont des
personnes
veut le faire une simple contre le lou
ceu qui régule ce soit la peur la
méfiance la colère et la haine
n'oubliez pas que c'est en résistant
aussi à ses passions que de vaincre ces
individus
qu'ils essaient de les faire prospérer
et comme je pense que nous avons
collectivement montré aujourd'hui que
nous étions capables d'aller au delà de
ces mauvaises passions que nous étions
capables de soutenir sans aucune
ambiguïté la liberté conscience liberté
d'expression la laïcité la primauté de
la loi vous avez les fans sur la loi
religieuse sur les tops le religieux je
pense que ce rassemblement est qu un
début
j'espère que dans les jours qui viennent
dans les semaines qui viennent des
quelques annonces soin des bêtes je
pense notamment à la fidl et haas a
sauvé de la liberté
aujourd'hui encore
gilardino ne réussirez pas parce que la
france la république française
fisam alcan pour faire en sorte de vous
faire goûter
vous faire faire des sauvegardes
individus valeur une petite surprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'ils sont
[Musique]
vous
quand
[Musique]
forcément connu des ventes
français
ces gens qui sont partis lundi
je pense
des boîtes noires
il abandonne
à tous dans
7 rassemblement place de la république à
paris rassemblement en hommage à samuel
pâtit 47 ans cet enseignant de collège
enseignants d'histoire-géographie
assassiné vendredi soir plusieurs
milliers de personnes place de la
république on attendra le chiffre des
autorités en fin de journée il y avait
des rassemblements similaires aussi à
marseille à lille à rodez à saint lô en
normandie bref toute la france qui a
voulu témoigner son effroi et et sa
gratitude aussi envers le milieu
enseignant s'est mobilisée notamment ici
au coeur de la capitale
on a vu aussi les responsables
politiques bien quitter le cortège
il ya quelques instants stanislas
guérini à la tête de la république en
marche un peu plus tôt on avait vu
l'écologiste yannick jadot on a vu aussi
jean luc mélenchon est le leader de la
france insoumise
un peu plus tôt vous avez pu apercevoir
si vous étiez avec nous jean castex le
chef du gouvernement
alors quelles seront les suites après ce
rassemblement et bien il y aura un
conseil de défense tout à l'heure dans
un peu plus d'une heure autour d'
emmanuel macron on va voir s'il y a deux
premières annonces ce soir avec le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
la semaine le coeur de la semaine pour
voir ce qu'il en sort dans le concret
dans les propositions on aura aussi
l'hommage national à samuel pâti
mercredi qu on vous fera vivre en direct
évidemment sur figaro live sur twitter
sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr
bien sûr d'ailleurs je vais profiter et
bien de cette référence à nos
plateformes pour vous saluer et vous
remercier d'avoir commenté
en tout cas pour ceux qui ont respecté
la charte même si c'est une journée
placée sous le sceau de la liberté
d'expression bien il faut aussi savoir
respecter toutes celles et tous ceux
vis-à-vis de qui est acquis on s'exprime
à merci en tout cas thierry ac scène
christian politique ali d'avoir été avec
nous sur lefigaro.fr merci miaou être
kiki lol merci à cracher d'avoir été
avec nous sur twitter
et merci à notre communauté youtube je
salue sajoo et hicham en particulier
très bonne fin de journée très bonne fin
de week end bonnes vacances si c'est le
cas et à très vite pour de nouvelles
actualités en direct sur figaro live